[Music]
let's borrow heads and pray
our father in heaven
we thank you god for your love
we thank you for this day you've given
to us
and for the freedom to worship you in
this country
and for this conference
where service to you is being emphasized
i ask you their god
as my father
and in the name of jesus my brother
put your words in my mouth
put your spirit in my heart
bless everyone listening i pray
but bless not only us
bless the sessions run by other speakers
that everywhere
something is going on your name may be
lifted up
and your people blessed
i offer this prayer from my heart
in jesus name let god's people say amen
and amen my presentations will be on the
subject of what
personal
excellence or you can just say
excellence
excellence is a spiritual quality
now we tend to
reserve religion
and religious behavior to
sabbath the church
spirituality
is not something you do on sabbath
is a way of life so that everything you
do
is an expression of who you are ellen
white says business and religion are the
same thing
education
and religion are the same thing
recreation
and we need to understand that now
excellence go with me to
ecclesiastes chapter nine
i usually ask for three favors let me
tell you what they are while you're
looking for ecclesiastes favor number
one
if you have one of these let me set the
example
please
turn it off
but in this small session
if you need it
for
ella white's writings or something you
may keep it on but you don't need sound
are you with me
and don't go to whatsapp
and don't go to uh what's the other
thing
facebook
and where else and snapchat and uh
there's one in china called wechat well
don't go to any of those things you know
that's the reason why i always say bring
a bible you see when you open this
there's no whatsapp
are you listening to me the devil is
very clever
he'll tell you but you have the bible
but you also have whatsapp you have
email you have a viber you have whatever
skype
when you open this what you have the
bible
so that you do not have the temptation
to text when you open this except the
bible text when you have this you are
surrounded by temptations
that's why i plead with people of all
ages
use this
you know when god described job he said
that the devil has thou considered my
servant job
there's none like him in the earth
a perfect
and an upright man now here's what god
says one that feareth god and estuarth
evil give me a word for estu
avoid
one of the best ways to resist sin is to
avoid it
that's why i say
use this
it has no whatsapp on it
what book did i say
what chapter
one verse
10 who has the king james version makes
your hands
all right someone with the king james
version reads that verse for us nice and
loud stand your feet so the camera can
catch you and make you a superstar and
read ecclesiastes 9 verse 10 who will
stand with courage and read for jesus
some good looking people stand up and
read for jesus ah here's a good looking
man god bless you for being confident
all right ecclesiastes night
whatsoever
do it if i might stop
no i said stop
stop stop stop
stop
s-t-o-p-e stop that's top e okay
the bible says
whatsoever thy hand finest to do let's
think
what does the word whatsoever exclude
nothing
what does it include
everything now because we're christians
it includes everything that's good
the verse does not mean
if you're robbing a bank do it with all
your heart are you with me it does not
mean commit
some moral act with all your heart
surely it means the things that please
god now
whatsoever you do
or whatsoever your hand findeth to do
what's the biblical command
come on my brother pop back up what's
your name
peter a good bible name now read the
whole verse brother peter whatsoever thy
hand sign it to do
do it with eye
why
the verse will tell you finish it
they'll tell you
for there's no uh-huh nor device go on
no wisdom
in the grave
thank you brother peter god bless you
are you married peter
you're married
you don't have a wife
oh sorry may the lord give you a wife
who can cook all right now the bible
says
whatsoever thy hand findeth to do now
who is working anyone working
what work you do
your office work
the bible says to you
do your office work how
with your might
now that's not the recommendation from
the bible that's a command the bible
commands us
to do our best
how often
come on how often
all the time
who else works
you have an office expert my handsome
brother what do you do you raise your
hands the man with a beard
your music teacher
what kind of music teacher should you be
what
yes but what kind of music teaches
should you be
based on that bible verse
all right let me help you
you should teach music with your might
it doesn't mean you must be a better
teacher than some other music teacher it
means you must be the best music teacher
you can be
whatsoever who's in school
on youtube no one in school on this okay
you're in school
college how many are in college
okay college okay hands down
high school
elementary school
kindergarten
or okay okay whatever whatever your
level of learning listen to me carefully
this is a command from god
the bible says
do it
with all your heart or your might
now god gives a philosophical reason
god always has
a reason
whether he tells you or not in this
verse he gives the reason
here is the reason you read the second
half of the verse stand up nice and tall
what's your name
joseph is a good bible name
what was the name of joseph's wife
you don't know mary all right
read the second part of the verse for
there's no
no device
no knowledge
no wisdom
ah in the great finish the first wither
thou goeth thank you brother joseph god
bless you
now here is the philosophy the bible is
saying
you are headed where
for the grace
on that journey
do the best you can because the grave
marks the end
and you will not have another chance
to go and live your life again
and make it a superior life and so god
says your life
is the only opportunity you have to do
your best
in other words this life is not a
rehearsal
this is it
whatsoever thy hand findeth to do
do it
with thy might
for there is no work
no device
nor knowledge nor wisdom in the grave
when you are dead that is the end of
your opportunity to live a life of
excellence now the word whatsoever means
if you're a mother
you must try to be the best mother you
can be you're a father you're an office
worker your music teacher your college
student you are a janitor you are a
deacon you are the pastor you're the
conference president you are an auditor
you are an accountant
which means if you listen to pastor
ramdan's call to give full service to
god you can give full service to god
while being a lawyer
are you with me
you can give full service to god while
being a dentist
everyone does not have to be a pastor or
call porter or a bible worker or some
medical missionary whatever line of
service you are in you are required by
god
to do your best
that is spiritual behavior as much as
praying and singing hymns
expressing
ex listen to god now how were we made
genesis 1 26 says what in le and god
said let us make man how
after our image let's see something
about god's image go to genesis 1.
genesis 1 our subject today is just
excellence as a general concept
genesis 1 let's learn something about
god
we go to uh
verse 31 of genesis 1.
the bible says
and god saw what
everything that he had made
now listen to ecclesiastes 9 10
whatsoever thy hand find it to do that
is the same thing as everything god had
made
now
and god saw
what do you mean by saw
what do you understand by saul
does it literally mean using the eyes
what do you think is meant by saw you
know god said let there be light and
there was light and god saw the likes
that it was good what did god do
he evaluated
he assessed
he examined and he concluded the light
was good
now genesis 1 31
for us nice and loud wherever you are
anyone
and god saw what
everything that he had made finish the
verse and behold it was what
now stop
in other words based on that verse what
conclusion can you draw about the way
god works
come on talk to me it may not be your
culture but break your culture today
what conclusion can you draw about the
way god works based on genesis 1 31
god works with excellence
how many things does god do excellently
everything
now genesis 1 26 says and god said let
us make man how
in our image
if you
are in god's image
how should you work
excellently
then if you are working sloppily
i'm about to make a very serious
statement
the universe has two standards
what are the two and they are wrapped up
in two individuals name the first one
god name the other one
satan
the bible is a book of opposites
you either follow god
or satan
god's way
is excellence
first corinthians 14 33 says god is not
the author of confusion
then if he is not the author of
confusion and there is confusion
who is the author of confusion
yes you must always answer with
confidence even when you're wrong
are you with me
always speak with boldness even when
you're
wrong god is not the author of confusion
but there is confusion then who is the
author of confusion what's your
conclusion satan now god is the
originator of excellence
god is the first person in the bible to
work
when you read genesis 1 1
in the beginning god created the heaven
and the earth that was work because in
genesis 2 verse 1 the bible says thus
the heavens and the earth were finished
and all the hosts of them verse 2 and on
the 7th day god ended his work creation
was work
that is what god rested from
and how does god describe his work and
god saw everything that he had made god
saw his work and behold finish the verse
it was
very good what am i saying god made us
in his image therefore when we work
what should god look down and say
very good
that is a reflection of god's image
are you following me
or are you sleepy
let me say it again
excellence in work
is a reflection of the glory and the
character of god
because that's how god worked
you go through genesis 1 from verse 3
and god said let there be light and
there was light and god saw the light
that it was good
god saw it it was good saw it it was
good all the way down in verse 31 he
sums it all up everything was very good
very important principle to take with
you excellence in what you do is divine
behavior
one way to behave like god is to do the
best in what you do
that's service to god
let me say it again you're quiet you
have a quiet
disposition
so i'm not sure if you're following me
or not
i'm accustomed to churches where people
talk back to you
shout and jump and do all kinds of
things but you just sit quietly like
gravestones so i'm not sure
what's going on
i said
excellence in behavior
in
action
in work
is an expression of divine behavior
all right
what does god expect
of his people
does he have a higher expectation for
you
than for the unbeliever
let's go to matthew five
our subject we're just looking at
excellence as an idea as a quality
matthew 5
i'm delighted to see those of you taking
notes you know god is a god who writes
how many times did he speak the ten
commandments
how many times come on you're too slow
how many times once how many times did
he write them
twice
so god is the god who writes
when the pharisees brought that woman
taken in adultery and jesus bent down
what did he do he
wrote god loves to write
second corinthians 3 verse 3
god writes his law on our hearts through
the holy spirit he writes that's what
second corinthians 3 3 says
all right what book did i say
matthew what chapter
5 reading from verse 46.
i want a young lady to stand gracefully
and read matthew 5 46
for if ye
love them who will stand and read
yes my sister stand up what's your name
melody's a good name musical name
okay brother the teacher here's a
musical student her name is melody all
right read matthew 5 46 what does it say
nice and loud
which love you
what reward have you
do not even the republicans
this yes sit now god bless you melody i
want to ask you if you're married god
bless you since the method
listen to jesus
if ye
love them
which love you
what reward have ye do not even the
publicans the same jesus is saying the
unbeliever does the same thing you have
to do something higher
melody you may stay seated read verse 47
and if you salute
you can stand that's okay
and if he
salute
uh-huh
what do you more than others
do not republican so
thank you my good sister jesus is saying
if you like those who like you you are
functioning at the level of the
unbeliever at the level of the heathen
and jesus says i want you to function
where
at a higher level
of excellence
i want you notice how verse 48 read
verse 48 nice allowed you all know it be
therefore perfect
keep reading even as your father which
is in heaven
is perfect now
we're talking about excellence
this is a remarkable standard
christ is telling us because the
disciples are dead we need those words
we must be
of function in such a way
that we do everything we can within our
human capability
as god does everything he can within his
divine capability
be
therefore perfect
perfection for the believer
requires that the believer function at a
higher level
than the unbeliever
now what do i mean by a higher level
let's go to mark 14 we shall read verse
8.
what are we discussing today
excellence as a general concept required
by god
mark 14
verse 8 very interesting statement from
the lips of jesus christ the woman has
come to anoint his feet before his death
the disciples criticized her judas said
it might have been sold the ointment and
the money given to the poor which really
he wanted the money for himself
here is how jesus characterized what the
woman did mark 14 verse 8 what does that
first line say what does jesus say nice
and loud if you have a king james what
does it say
she
has done what
ah
let me ask you a very tricky question
let me ask this side
can you do
your best
and still do less than someone else
yes
do you agree
you see
biblical excellence
does not involve competition with others
biblical excellence involves competition
with yourself
in other words
god is saying i have given you so many
talents and skills that's what i've
given to melody that's what i've given
to peter that's what i've given to
joseph
now i want joseph to do the best he can
with what i've given him with no regard
for what peter has because i will deal
with peter individually
now if you understand that you do not
compete in college against your friends
that is anti-god that goes contrary to
god that is satanic
to measure yourself by someone else that
is not godly excellence that is satanic
that requires the elevation of self i
must outdo him i must outdo her
god says randy skeet
i give you a gift
you use it
to the maximum that you can because i
will judge you not by what he has but by
what i has given you i have given you
biblical excellence does not involve
competition with others
it involves competition
against the capabilities god has given
you
you know what is more valid how many of
you wish you were geniuses can i see
your hand
can you name someone who's regarded as a
genius in the past let's say the 20th
century who's regarded as a genius
ice time yeah every einstein way back
before einstein leonardo da vinci
another
genius let me tell you something that is
more valuable than genius
discipline
is that capacity
to do your duty
regardless of what is going on around
you
years ago
nike had a slogan a saying
what was the saying
just that his discipline so you say mr
discipline it's raining and mr
discipline says what
just do it i don't care if it's raining
mr discipline
there's a flood in some of the malaysian
states and discipline says i don't care
there's a fellow
who's on youtube he's an exercise
bodybuilder he has a philosophy which is
very very
biblical but he uses a lot of profane
language to express it
he says when you're in the gym
he doesn't care if your father died
or is dying
if your wife is in the process of
divorcing you
your children are in prison
your house is burning he says i don't
care
all i care is it's your set at that
machine
go to the bench press it's your set i
don't care where your wife is or your
bank account is who's killing your
children who is stealing your car it's
your set
god says to you
my son
my daughter
i give you capacities capabilities i
give you strengths now
i don't care what the circumstance is i
want you to do your best
listen to ellen white
god's amazing grace
page 271
paragraph two
i'll let you write that down
god's amazing grace
page 271
paragraph two
the quotation says
god requires
that his servants excel others
in life and character
let me say it again
god expects or requires
his servants to excel others in life
and character now you may say that's
competition it's not really competition
what god is saying if you are connected
to me
and they are not
if you have divine assistance and they
do not who should be at a higher level
of excellence
the one
connected to god so god is not promoting
competition he is saying it makes sense
for someone to expect a believer to
excel because the believer is associated
with divine power
excellence
is a very serious concept
god requires it and he will not back
away from that requirement there is
nothing in god that tolerates mediocrity
nothing
if you love them which love you
what do we eat more than others
or what reward have you
and if you salute them
that salute you
what do you more than others
i need you says christ to function at
the level just like god and that is
you do the best in your sphere as god is
the best in his you know micah says in
micah 7 18 who is a god like unto thee
there is no other
there is no other god like god because
our god is so excellent
and if we were faithful to god
the world would be saying
there is no other people like whom
come on don't break my heart like home
like home
seventh-day adventists
excellent
in family life
excellent in business
excellent in education excellent in
health excellent in worship excellent in
social structure excellent in every
expression of human life the world
should be saying who are these people
the children score at the top of all the
subjects and yet they spend so much time
in the bible
and in missionary work
how is that possible
because they realize
excellence is divinely required by god
it is an expression of godly behavior
and if you turn that coin to the
opposite side
mediocrity is satanic behavior
and so as you sit where you sit
god has a moral
let me say differently excellence is a
moral requirement
let me ask you a question
how many of you are immoral makes your
hand
how many of you are immoral raise your
okay how many of you have ever told a
lie raise your hand just a little small
microscopic mosquito of a lie just raise
your hand okay okay hands down how many
of you have ever broken the sabbath at
least once
all right how many of you
are immoral
now when you think of immorality what do
you think of come on fornication
adultery
lesbianism
uh all the other ism
that is immorality let me tell you
something the ten commandments are a
moral law
are you with me
from one to ten
sabbath breaking is immorality
as much as adultery
and
mediocrity in our work is immorality
anything god requires of us in our
conduct
is a moral has a moral side let me say
it again
excellence is a moral requirement
slackness mediocrity is immoral behavior
so i don't want you to associate
excellence with a plus and a hundred out
of a hundred that's fine that's proper
but the higher level is that this is
moral behavior
when i perform less than i am capable of
performing
i am engaging
in immoral behavior
and we serve a moral god
not an immoral god
my brothers and sisters
the reason why many of us are not
further along
is because we do not recognize
excellence as a central facet of the
christian life
jesus said of that woman
she have done what
she could meaning she could do no more
do you realize the sacrifice of christ
was the most excellent sacrifice there
was nothing else god could do god was at
his highest
in excellence when he said christ could
he have sent an angel yes or no
yes would that have been the height of
excellence no
that would have been a lower standard
god sent someone equal with himself that
excellence at his highest
you serve a god that specializes
in excellence
and so i go back to micah 7
who is a god
like unto thee or isaiah 40 25 to whom
then will he liken me or shall i be
equal saith the holy one is there anyone
to whom you can compare me says god and
the answer is no let me tell you
something if we embrace this concept of
excellence in every area of life the
world will say the same thing about us
listen to these words from ellen white
early writings page 227
paragraph one
i saw that when you read eloise writings
and you see i
saw
sit up
or i was shown
sit up or i was instructed
she said i
saw
that if the church had always retained
her peculiar holy character
the power of the holy spirit which was
committed to the disciples would still
be with her she goes on to say the sick
would be healed demons will be cast out
the sick would be healed and she would
be mighty and a terror
to her enemies
when the israelites were coming out of
the wilderness in the days of rehab the
harlot
in what city did rahab live quickly
jericho
remember the spies came to her house
and she hid them she said to them just
before they went to bed we have heard
how the lord dried up the waters of the
red sea for you
when you came up out of egypt
and what she did to the two kings that
were on the other side jordan saihon and
og whom he utterly destroyed she said we
have heard
and as soon as we had heard these things
our hearts did melt
she had heard of the remarkable
achievements of the israelites why they
were led by god they were being led by
joshua and under joshua they were more
faithful than under moses
and she said we are trembling
because we are facing a people we cannot
handle now what am i saying
if we were faithful to god as we should
excellent in everything the world would
be afraid of us
do not
get in the way of adventists
there serve a god that will blot you off
the face of the earth
if we wanted to build a church the town
council would say
yes
you want to expand your school yes
why
because we are faithful to god
but in what condition do we find
ourselves today nobody knows who
adventists are
in the united states i think only about
50 of people have heard of adventists
but everyone has heard of al qaeda
they are more excellent in what they do
than what we've been called to do
let me pause
i want you to respond to me when you
answer speak loudly you're being taped
i'll just reply uh re repeat what you
say
someone on this side what have you heard
so far this morning someone on this side
quickly don't make us wait
time is flying
and if you're too slow i'm going to this
side
all right this side what have you heard
someone tell me
what have i said
do everything with your mind so i said
that god said that and where is that
found
don't look sister no cheating where is
it found
ecclesiastes 9
verse 10. god bless you someone else
what have you heard
yes there's something more precious than
genius and that is discipline
let me tell you if you are disciplined
in school you will succeed
you're disciplined in your work you'll
succeed you discipline in bible study
you'll be a bible scholar without having
to go to the seminary discipline
discipline in your exercise program
you'll be fit
discipline and raising your children
you'll raise them for the glory of god
discipline
we are some of the most ill disciplined
and undisciplined people on the face of
the earth disciplined
what have you heard somebody else
come on you haven't got all day
excellence is a moral requirement and
god is a moral god and we were made in
the image of a moral god of whom it is
said and god saw everything that he had
made and behold it was very good you and
i every friday that comes by before we
keep the sabbath we should look back on
a week of work and say and peter and
joseph and melody saw everything that
they had made and behold finish the
words
very good
then you can rest and keep the sabbath
a person who is mediocre cannot keep the
sabbath
now you can physically rest you can't
keep this happen
to keep the sabbath you must be like god
your work during the week must be
described as your best
that prepares you
to rest because you realize only god
could have done more
excellence in what you do
that gives you peace of mind
i have studied as hard as i could now i
take the exam with peace of mind
god expects more of us
than he does of the unbeliever
why because we are connected to the
source of all power
that is god
it just makes sense
remember the story of the three hebrew
boys
in babylon
after three years of study what does the
bible say of them nebuchadnezzar found
them what ten and i'm getting to that
when i talk about educational excellence
ten
times better
now that part of daniel is not symbolic
you see daniel has historical and
prophetic that part is not his story
it's not prophetic it's not symbolic it
is literal
nebuchadnezzar found them
times
better
why verse 17 because gave the god gave
them knowledge and skill in our learning
and wisdom why as a reward for their
efforts
my young brothers and sisters
excellence is a moral requirement
excellence can also be a habit
the same way always being late for
church and work is a habit
you can make excellence a habit
let me say
another thing about excellence it is not
something you do first
let me say that again excellence is not
first something you do
if a bird never flies is it still a bird
yes or no
yes
if a crocodile never snatched someone in
its jaws is it still a crocodile yes
if a scorpion never stung anyone is it
still a scorpion yes now what am i
saying
excellence is not first what you do
excellence is
now i want some excellent person
to read my mind
and finish my thoughts listen to me
excellence is not first what you do
excellence first is
ah who said that
ah god bless you nice young man
handsome fellow looks like me yes
excellence is not what you do
excellence is who you are
[Music]
so whenever you've got something to do
automatically
you do it well
you know there's a there's a customer
united states i don't know if it's in
malaysia
we tip for everything
you get in the cab you tip
you go to the restaurant you tip
someone brings you something you give a
tip
it is so built into the system that some
people base the quality of their work
based on the size of the tip
are you following me
if you tip big
if i get a little tip then i put
something in your food that
makes you lose your mind
not the christian
the christian's quality of work has
nothing to do with a tip
it has to do with his character
or her character i say again excellence
is not first what you do
excellence is who you are
and so someone said to you vacuum this
room
what is your natural automatic desire
to vacuum it so well
that someone following you could not
find a speck of dust
to vacuum so well who alone could vacuum
better god
let me tell you a story and i closed
this session
in african-american history there's a
fellow called booker t washington
a well-known figure in african-american
history he was a slave
but he desired to go to school very
badly he wanted to learn to read and
write and advance himself
and so he uh
i don't recall if he would god he
escaped or he was freed or whatever it
was anyway he left his home in the south
and journeyed hundreds of miles to a
school called the hampton institute
uh in virginia virginia i think it is it
took him weeks
he would steal rides on trains sleep on
the sidewalk
eat from garbage cans and when he
finally got to the school he was in rags
barefooted and he saw the school
and he went up to the window and he
looked in
and he looked at the students nicely
dressed all white students there
a white teacher a lady
and his heart yearned to be in that
school to learn
and the lady saw him the teacher she
came to the window you know there's a
slavery you know black people were
treated like what do you want
he said i want to go to school
she looked at him
she just looked at him this is an
escaped slave
and remarkably she said to him come with
me
she took him to a room a classroom
and she said
clean this room
and then she left
and went back to teach the students
when he was done he came and told her he
was done
she took
a handkerchief a white one
and went to the classroom
and she uh
did that
no dust
she went under another desk and she
she
no dust
wherever she went finish it
no that's that's a good sermon title no
dust
she called him
and she admitted him to school on the
spot
you know why
she said if that's the way he cleans a
room
how well will he do in his classroom
that was a statement of his character a
slave cleaning a classroom and the
excellence of his work
and he became one of the leading figures
he fraternized with presidents in his
adult years
he counsel president
he set up a school
a well-known figure how did he begin
an escaped slave who was asked to clean
a room
and he cleaned it with such excellence
he was admitted to school and became a
towering historical figure my brothers
my sisters
excellence is a requirement that god has
placed on you
excellence
is not first what you do
excellence is what
who you are
excellence is a moral
requirement
and god expects those connected to him
to excel others in life and in character
god's amazing grace page 271 paragraph
two
and our bible verse
whatsoever thy hand findeth to do
do it how
with thy might why for there is no work
not advice
nor knowledge nor wisdom in the grave
wither thou goest and so the bible gives
the philosophy you have one chance to do
well
do it
let me tell you from my heart as your
older brother
excellence is spiritual behavior
i also said excellence does not mean
competing with others it means doing the
best based on what god has given to you
that's why he said of that woman in mark
14 verse 8 she had done what she could
now someone else may be able to do more
but the fact you can do more does not
mean god is more impressed god just
wants to know is that more
connected to the abilities i have given
you
let me pause
any questions
let me take a break
because i have to come right back and do
session two and this time it'll be
excellence in education and i know you
love that
any questions there must be questions
you see when you think
questions you generated any questions
you see when you don't have questions it
means one of two things that you
understood nothing
or it was so clear there's no need for
questions and only god can make
something that clear i care
are they any questions
let me thank you for not getting up and
walking out god bless you for
cooperating
i say that from my heart god bless you
any questions
all right yes my good brother
how do we know if our excellence is on
par with god's excellence did you hear
that question how do we know if our
excellence is on par with god that's a
very good question i don't have
specifics for you all i can say to you
mike what's your name
glenn is not a bible name but it's a
good name brother glenn
you must know in your heart
that you only you and god can know i
have done the very best i can have i
exhausted all possibilities have i
exerted myself to the limit you alone
can know that and god has a way about
the glenn of speaking to the heart
through the convicting work of his
spirit to let you know
you're falling short or you're coming up
to the mark and so while i have no
specifics all i can say is god will let
you know
that you have done
your best
in the task he has assigned you
there is never an occasion you know this
morning pastor ramdan said
the best time to follow christ is always
now
with god
doing things excellent is always
required or there are no exceptions
none
any other questions
yes what's your name my good brother
joseph we have joseph we have joseph all
right yes joseph what's your question
this imitation lead to excellence it
depends on whom you imitate now paul
told the believers you know follow him
as he followed jesus yes there is some
uh place for imitation because an image
imitates the original
so when you're made in god's image you
are to imitate god you are to imitate
christ
but that imitation is internal it is
organic it is cellular am i using
difficult words my good translator it
comes from the very bottom are you
following me it's not a surface
imitation it comes from your soul
and that imitation now there are people
called uh
there are some people who can stand up
and imitate other people they can talk
like barack obama and you think you're
listening to barack obama or they can
talk like i don't know somebody else
that's not what biblical imitation is
imitation is not just do it like it is
almost become
so that you and christ become one that's
the ultimate imitation
imitation that's biblical requires a
fusion of two people you and christ
become one so that paul can say i am
crucified with christ nevertheless i
live yet not i what are the next few
words but christ that's the highest form
of imitation any other question
all right
let's pray we close this session
head bowed eyes closed
our father in heaven thank you so much
for setting a high standard for your
people
we pray in the name of jesus dear god
that as a result of this presentation
your young men young women will leave
this place with the consciousness
that it is morally required of us
to do our best
it is an expression of divine behavior
your word commands requires and demands
whatsoever thy hand fineth to do do it
with thy might
meaning with everything we have
please god
help that to become a reality in our
lives i pray
whether the task is small or big
public or private whether we receive
recognition of god or not we must
function like god
and that one way father is to do our
very best we thank you the god for doing
your best at creation and for doing your
best in salvation
now father bless us
and prepare us for the next presentation
i pray in jesus name let god's people
say amen and amen
you